[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une europe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 27 avril le
déconfinement approche en france réunion
entre emmanuel macron lmr par visio
conférence est après midi pour le
préparer le calendrier sera détaillé au
plus tard le 5 mai lorsque emmanuel
macron prendra la parole
l'allègement devrait être progressif et
territorialisée avec la réouverture des
commerces non essentiels et les
terrasses à la mi mai mais l'incertitude
demeure en raison de la situation
sanitaire toujours inquiétante alors que
près de six mille patients sont en
réanimation
décryptage à suivre bruno le maire
presse la commission européenne de
rendre son plan de relance
opérationnelle en tout 750 milliards
d'euros décidé l'été dernier
la france devrait recevoir 40 millions
40 milliards d'euros soit une partie des
100 milliards du plan national lors d'un
point presse avec son homologue allemand
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'économie
n'a pas caché son agacement
nous avons perdu trop de temps c'est ce
qu'il a déclaré sion l'épidémie de que
vit dix neuf at elle précipité la chute
de jei reboulh sonar ou une commission
d' enquête sur la gestion de la pandémie
s'ouvre aujourd'hui au brésil ces
conclusions pourraient ouvrir la voie à
une procédure de destitution du
président brésilien
jahia molson arrow qui menacent de faire
intervenir l'armée pour mettre un terme
au confinement locaux alors que le
brésil est très proche des 400 mille
morts dus coronavirus
[Musique]
dans un contexte sanitaire toujours
tendu le déconfinement pose question les
indicateurs restent élevés les hôpitaux
sont forcés de déprogrammer les
opérations non urgentes
et cela inquiète forcément les
personnels soignants angoisse la
dégringolade aussi est il responsable
d'alléger les mesures de restriction à
partir du mois prochain une question
légitime qui s'invite dans les débats
ces derniers jours alors que le chef de
l'état prévoit de lever les contraintes
à travers une succession d'étapes pour
cela l'exécutif compte sur la décrue du
nombre de contaminations amorcé ces
derniers temps la situation elle est
sous contrôle dans la mesure où vous le
savez aujourd'hui à l'heure à laquelle
je vous parle
l'épidémie a plutôt tendance à régresser
elle ne régresse pas aussi vite que je
souhaiterais qu'elle régresse et que les
français de souhaiterait évidemment mais
nous sommes passés de quelques quarante
mille cas diagnostiqués par jour un
petit peu moins de trente mille cas ce
qui est encore en haut niveau de
circulation du virus ce qui appliqué
nous devons encore poursuivre nos
efforts notamment dans la lutte contre
la diffusion de ces variants qui on le
sait sont plus contagieuses une tendance
à la baisse qui pourrait s'appliquer
aussi dans les services de réanimation
reste que pour l'heure les indicateurs
restent particulièrement élevé la barre
des 6000 patients qu'aux vide en soins
critiques étaient atteintes ce lundi un
chiffre qui témoigne d'une tension
hospitalière encore très soutenue au
bout de la chaîne
l'effet domino est bien visible les
équipes chirurgicales devront dès que
possible et rattraper le retard accumulé
du fait des déprogrammations
d'opérations non urgentes
un levier qui permet de libérer des lits
et du personnel médical
à ce jour nous sommes à peu près 1 60%
de déprogrammation par rapport à notre
activité normale
bien sûr ça induit
deux de gros problèmes des gros
problèmes organisationnels au sein de
l'hôpital
beaucoup de frustration dans les équipes
chirurgicale donc vous dire que c'est
aux nabeul oui de toute façon n'avons
pas le navre ont pas le choix
notre objectif est de reprendre les plus
rapidement possible une activité normale
tout en conservant deux missions de
service public qui sont de prendre en
charge les patients malades ducobu quoi
qu'il en soit les français attendent
désormais que le fou se disperse autour
du calendrier des réouvertures qui
devrait bel et bien se faire en ordre
dispersé
le chef de l'état qui a multiplié les
déplacements ces derniers jours à la
proche d'un déconfinement normalement
prévue en mai pourront par les ont
rejoints tout de suite
alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poulard merci
d'être avec nous alors emmanuel macron
il est sur tous les fronts est ce que
c'est normal ou pas vu le contexte
sanitaire et sécuritaire aussi alors il
est sur tous les fronts mais est-ce
qu'ils gouvernent c'est la question on a
l'impression de voir là un candidat
totalement erratique qui est tous les
jours qui apparaît quelque part alors
une fois dans une salle de classe une
fois sur le toit de notre dame une fois
avec la bac de montpellier une fois dans
un service de réanimation
on ne sait jamais où il va être
d'ailleurs ils ne partagent plus son
agenda de la semaine avec les
journalistes donc c'est toujours une
surprise mais ils s'arrangent toujours
bien sûr pour que les caméras soient là
et pour répondre et pour prendre le
contre-pied finalement de là où on
attend une chose est sûre c'est que si
il y à une seule façon de gouverner ça
reste quand même le mercredi le conseil
des ministres et surtout le conseil de
défense à cette réunion placée sous le
secret défense où il décide de tout et
de n'importe quoi concernant cette crise
du coc vide à la fois des dates de
réouverture des dates de fermeture des
horaires du couvre feu
peut-être même du tarif des amendes je
ne sais pas comment ça fonctionne
d'ailleurs personne ne le sait la
transparence n'est pas au rendez vous et
les contrôle démocratique n'existe plus
puisque tout se décide de manière ultra
centralisée par l'épidémiologiste en
chef de l'élysée qui est en campagne
clairement puisqu'il change de costume
tous les jours et il ira costumes
finalement on a du mal à le voir
endosser celui évidemment de président
on a l'impression que il ne gouverne
plus et que la france est finalement
dans une improvisation permanente faso
chiffres du virus 6000 patients en
réanimation aujourd'hui des écoles qui
ont fermé et qui ouvre alors que toutes
les courbes sont en train de monter plus
ou moins et des dates qu'on va tenir
mais on ne sait pas comment encore un
flou entretenu par ce président qui
parle non plus de chiffres ni vraiment
de date mais qui donne des données en
disant on verra on verra
il ya des paliers à partir de mi-mai et
puis là où ça circule beaucoup
on verra si on ouvre ou pas alors
beaucoup c'est pas un chiffre est donc
tout est à longvic et c'est ainsi que
emmanuel macron gère cette crise en
candidat dans une surenchère de
communication qu'il gère cette crise en
candidat mais on se dit aussi qu'il ait
forcé quelque part de défendre son bilan
puisqu'il est sur le terrain aussi pour
rendre des comptes lutter contre cette
crise sanitaire
oui alors son bilan s'il veut le
défendre il n'est pas bon et c'est bien
pour ça qu'il s'agite dans tous les sens
et qu'il fait autant de communication
pour allumer des contre-feux le
séparatisme la loi sur le terrorisme qui
étaient là bien avant attentats
tragiques à rambouillet et puis tous les
thèmes qu'il va pouvoir faire monter
finalement la laïcité pour faire oublier
son bilan sanitaire qui est
catastrophique
cent mille morts 6000 patients en
réanimation des vaccinations qui font
toujours des couacs 1 malgré les
vaccinodromes on voit bien que des
personnes souhaitent se faire vacciner
et ne l'ont toujours pas les rendez vous
qu'elle attende et et des chiffres alors
qu'ils sont lancés comme ça par jean
castex par lui parle du révérend dire on
vise les 20 millions on vise les 30
millions de vaccinés premières doses à
partir du mois de juin
mais tout ça dans un une sorte de
brouillon une bonne brouillard de
communication parce que oui il ne veut
pas assumer le costume qui bien sûr le
l'embêtent le plus c'est celui de
monsieur cent mille morts là c'est
clairement un échec flagrant de cette
politique sanitaire et puis revenir en
arrière sur le fiasco des masques quand
il n'était inutile qu'il n'y en avait
pas maintenant on se pose la question du
masque en extérieur quand même est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir l'enlever ce masque à
l'extérieur si on est tout seul dans la
nature ou dans la rue ou sur une plage
le couvre-feu devant un élève de cm2 il
dit que oui 19h c'est peut-être un peu
tôt il va peut-être falloir
changer l'horaire de ce couvre-feu vu
qu'il fait jour plus longtemps mais tout
ça c'est lui qui décide et c'est bien là
où le bât blesse c'est que derrière ce
choix de vouloir incarner la décision au
plus haut niveau en étant le seul à
décider de tout eh bien il va être le
seul aussi à être le responsable
rappelez vous lors de la sphère benalla
on va bientôt fêter le 1er mai c'était
de collaborateurs développent macron
déguisé en policier il avait dit il n'ya
qu'un seul responsable
et c'est moi qui viennent le chercher eh
bien il est encore une fois le seul
responsable si fiasco il ya et
aujourd'hui ce bilan sanitaire est
plutôt catastrophique pour lui alors
vous disiez il change de costume se
présente comme un candidat c'est vrai
qu'on est à un an d'une échéance
importante l'élection présidentielle
c'est trop tôt pour changer de costume
comme vous dites alors elle ma confiance
tout le temps de costumes même de
déguisements on l'a vu à peu près dans
toutes les tenues possibles et
imaginables
sauf encore avoir à voir si déguisera en
mascotte de l'équipe de france ça ça
pourrait venir prochainement nom
emmanuel macron il est en campagne
permanente parce qu'il est à la tête
d'un parti qui n'existe quasiment plus
la république en marche est en train de
s'auto dissoudre à la fois par les
nombreuses défections à l'assemblée
nationale par les groupes dissidents qui
viennent de cette majorité
présidentielle et donc il est en train
de reconstruire une majorité de
dépassement avec le modem mais avec
d'autres pour préparer 2022 dès
maintenant avec la campagne des causes
en disant que maintenant vous allez
choisir des causes que soit le féminisme
l'écologie ou autre et vous allez faire
une majorité présidentielle pour porter
cette candidature du président en 2022
et donc il est en campagne dès à présent
parce que oui il est le seul à être
responsable c'est comme ça qu'il veut se
présenter devant les français et donc il
devra avoir un bilan positif s'il veut
avoir une chance d'être réélu et de
passer le premier tour ce qui n'est pas
du tout donné aujourd'hui à un an des
élections
donc il il fait tout pour sans parti
sans appareil finalement et on voit que
il n'y travaille beaucoup pour ça il
fait quoi de la communication de l'
influence
d'ailleurs on attend toujours ça fait
soixante trois jours qu'on attend cette
vidéo youtube avec les influenceurs
mcfly et carlito qui devait faire une
vidéo à l'elysée
ça je pense qu'il la garde dans les
cartons pour le dernier rendent pour
aller chercher l'électorat le plus jeune
en 2022 aujourd'hui il parle à
l'électorat de droite il sait que c'est
là qu'il peut prendre des voix d'où
toute cette flambée sécuritaire d
entretien au figaro des lois insécurité
global anti terrorisme etc
il va être très présent sur ce terrain
là pour à la fois couper l'herbe sous le
pied de marine le pen mais aussi d'un
potentiel candidat des républicains
et puis il sait qu'à gauche ce sera très
difficile pour lui de défendre un bilan
on voit la loi pma pour toutes qui est
finalement défendu en catimini qui n'est
pas vraiment montré comme un emblème de
la république en marche donc c'est lui
qui va gérer sa campagne
seul finalement en cherchant à aller
chercher des alliances
là où elles peuvent encore exister seul
est ce qu'il est vraiment seuls emmanuel
macron il ya ce trio castex darmanin
avérant est-ce qu'elle va aller au bout
avec les mêmes vous pensez alors il ya
d'abord des élections régionales en juin
qui seront une première sanction pour
les listes de la république en marche
qui sont très mal positionné dans les
sondages on voit d'ailleurs que les
ténors de la majorité ne souhaite pas se
présenter jean-michel blanquer remise de
l'éducation a refusé d'être candidat
dans la région ile de france
et finalement c'est marlène schiappa qui
est poussé pour représenter paris mais
pas l'ile-de-france c'est monsieur de
saint martin qui gérera la liste la
république en marche et partout ailleurs
les et c'est plutôt d'aider des gens qui
sont moins connus du grand public que
les ministres les plus connus cela il
veut les garder
clairement jean castex sera
potentiellement un fusible si les
résultats des municipales ne sont pas au
niveau et si la vaccination n'atteint
pas les chiffres énoncés et si le bilan
sanitaire reste aussi faible compte tenu
des des cent mille morts qui ne font
qu'augmenter depuis le début de l'année
donc on est en train de devoir
effectivement peut-être à un remaniement
ministériel un nouveau premier ministre
mais encore une fois quand je dis qu'il
est seul c'est parce qu'il a très peu de
figures politiques avec l'expérience
nécessaire pour être premier ministre ou
bien ministre de l'intérieur ou ministre
du budget on a l'impression qu'il a déjà
sorti toutes ses cartouches et qu'il
aura bien du mal à recruter de nouveaux
talents ou de nouvelles personnalités
issues des rangs de la droite ou de la
gauche comme s'il avait atteint son
plafond de verre et c'est bien pour ça
que je dis qu'il est seul il aura du mal
faire le coup de 2010 est où il avait pu
construire cet appareil qui est la
république en marche aujourd'hui je
crois que tous les gens qui le
soutiennent sont autour de lui peut-être
christian estrosi attente il un
strapontin et de trois personnes comme
lui qui feront défection des
républicains ou encore death qui reste
du parti socialiste mais ce sera à la
marge
compte tenu de ce qui a été fait depuis
2010 est merci beaucoup à vous à l'excès
poulin et d'état ria liste pour le
moment les étapes à du thé confinement
sont inconnues un calendrier incertain
qui inquiète les commerçants et les
restaurateurs c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
bonsoir à isabelle sékaly no vous êtes
présidente d'honneur de l'association
commerciale hyéroise et bonsoir à vous
également frédéric jeanjean
restaurateurs secrétaire générale de
l'umih 13
on est proche des 6000 cas de en
réanimation en soins critiques
regardez ces chiffres on voit que lors
des deux derniers confinement on était
sur des chiffres bien plus bas
aujourd'hui les commerces non essentiels
devraient rouvrir le 15 mai c'est ce qui
est annoncé en fonction d'ailleurs des
territoires idem pour les terrasses à
l'animé et les restaurants peut-être en
totalité dans certaines régions comment
vous avez accueilli ces mesures qui sont
annoncées dans ce contexte sanitaire
très tendu isabelle c'est calinaud alors
déjà si le diabète pourquoi nos mémoires
une coupe et on l'espère avancer une
compagne d'envoyer des chaussures usées
est trop petit pour les enfants à nos
ministres ou qu'ils comprennent bien qui
semblait me semble essentielle
et puis nous inquiétons doublement parce
qu'on se rend compte que tout ce qu'on
appelle servir à rien ou fermées pour
quoi faire puisque toute façon on
continue toujours avoir des problèmes de
santé
et d'après de pouvoir recevoir tous des
malades à l'hôpital
donc je pense qu'il ya eu un souci
important de faire quelque chose sans
réfléchir
quand j'ai appris que les sex shops été
ouvert dans paris là j'ai rebondi jeudi
mais c'est pas possible on empêche les
enfants d'acheter des chaussures des
adultes de changer l'heure
ceux qui sont des fois bien usé et on
vous fait rien pour nous on concédera
décidé quelques-uns dont nos collègues
qui nous a envoyé un message sur
facebook en demandant on aura des
chaussures un mini show ce qu'on a fait
donc lundi à hier les gars puis de notre
mère nous avons eu des trois collègues
d'envoyer des chaussures à nos ministres
dont qui boitait pas c'est simplement
une question de mode les chaussures
c'est essentiel frédéric jeanjean à
votre niveau
comment est ce que vous envisagez
justement les recettes potentielles
réouverture des terrasses et qui
peut-être des restaurants dans certaines
régions en fonction justement du taux
d'incidence en août et dans les
différents calendriers que nous avons pu
aborder avec le gouvernement il nous
avait été dit que quand le président
république alors et il y aurait trois
semaines de délai pour se comparer à la
réouverture
nous sommes remplis à la fin du mois
d'avril
il n'a toujours pas pris la parole la
réouverture ou qu'elle se met semble
fortement compromise il va falloir voir
l horizon cela va s'amorcer en tant qu'
une réouverture
ça se fait pas en claquant des doigts je
vous rappelle que nous sommes nous
dépendant de notre de nos filières
derrière le nom figure donc vous avez
les agriculteurs les éleveurs les
producteurs on va pas du jour au
lendemain
décidé d'abattre je ne sais combien de
têtes de bétail ou de volaille ou deux
profs ce soir ça prend du temps pour se
préparer
il ya toute la chaîne logistique c'est à
dire qu'il y a les transporteurs et les
commerciaux ou la prise de commande et
il ya tout ça qui doit se mettre en
place ça se fait pas en claquant des
doigts
le président de la république à nation
aux semaines de préparation pour
l'instant il a toujours pas pris la
parole
nous attendons de voir comment ça va se
passer alors justement le
le medef impasse km il ya quand même des
jours fériés qui s'annonce l'ascension
le 13 mai et le medef a fait pression
pour une réouverture partielle au no 2
des commerces avant dès le 10 mai ma
main pour permettre justement de
reprendre une activité qui soit
le creative avec des chiffres d'affaires
de bons chiffres d'affaires en
perspective pour vous ouvrir le 15 mai
éventuellement c'est trop tard il est
déjà trop tard
l'ouverture pour nous ça serait le 3 mai
après c'est trop tard et puis nous avons
respecté nos saisons parce que les
commandes prochaine qui vont nous
arriver c'est l'hiver voyez dans quelles
conditions va être question de stock
question de trouver de la place pour
mettre nos boîtes de chaussures
donc si on n'ouvre pas le 3 mai on est
tous morts n'est pas dû qu'au ville
comme aura multi bien d'une crise qui a
été mal jugé malsain et vous êtes prêt à
réouvrir la nation donc ça contrairement
aux restaurateurs qui ont besoin d'un
peu plus de temps près des règles en
jambes
oui tout à fait ce que je vous disais il
nous faut un peu de temps pour nous
organiser parce que vous imaginez bien
que nous avons toute une logistique à
mettre en place
je vous donne un exemple très concret
très simple avec les ouvertures et
fermetures successives que nous avons eu
dans mon établissement qui est un
établissement qui a été ouvert en 1886
français étant bien marseille quelque
chose de là bas c'est connu historique
et bien lors d'une interview avec un de
vos confrères
on me demandait quels étaient les elfes
les effets immédiats j'ai dit c'est très
simple mon établissement un colis de
guerre mondiale ne survivra pas à 50 de
gestion technocratique macro nist vous
savez je vous donne un exemple concret
mongongu voir avec les fermetures
il a fallu à chaque fois coupé
l'électricité et bien les frigos qui
était dedans l'eau s'est évaporée dans
le plancher
les frigos se sont décrochés puisque le
bois qui les soutenaient à sécher donc
il faut changer tout le comptoir
maintenant donc ça c'est des
investissements s'est pas pris en charge
par les assurances s'est pas blessé pris
en charge par personne et le comptoir ça
coûte cher
j'étais cet après midi chez des
confrères c'est les frigos qui ont lâché
à force d'être allumée et un allumé et
éteint les frire les moteurs ont lâché
donc là il ya ces problématiques là
derrière la problématique des
marchandises
ensuite la problématique du personnel
parce que nous étions avant le problème
de l'épidémie dans des situations
tendues
en terme d'emploi et aujourd'hui nous
nous rendons compte que nous avons nos
salariés qui font défection pour une
simple et bonne raison ils ont réussi à
trouver des emplois dans d'autres
secteurs économiques qui leur permettent
d'avoir le salaire à 100 % et donc ils
ont eu des changements d'orientation
professionnelle
on va avoir une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
à laquelle va se rajouter derrière la
problématique des apprentis qui depuis
un an n'ont pas eu de stage pratique
ils n'ont eu que de la théorie et vont
arriver à la réouverture dans nos
établissements sans savoir comment
pratiquer comment procéder alors que les
techniques été acquise au fur et à
mesure du temps sur des stratégies
justement du gouvernement déconfinement
progressif territorialisée surtout vous
par exemple frédéric jeanjean est ce que
vous êtes à marseille ce que vous
espérez pouvoir rouvrir ou pas mais on
va être très simple s'il faut attendre
une semaine ou dix jours de plus dans le
métier
nous attendrons mais par contre une fois
que nous ouvrirons il est hors de
question d'envisager que nous fermions
ensuite à nouveau au fur et à mesure
avec des couvre-feux avec un pas de deux
seins qu'on avance impôts un recul et au
final on va surtout au tribunal de
commerce
alors maintenant ça suffit alors nous
partagerons les a transférés leno est
tout à fait d'accord cette nuit là où on
en est et sebha crier les uns et des
autres donc il faut qu'on avance et que
nous tous il qu'on puisse vivre mais je
trouve que l'état le propre à côte notre
détresse parce qu'on est fatigué on en a
ras-le-bol
il tournera que les mesures ne servent
strictement à rien ça suffit il faut
avancer tout vivre je n'ai asséné permet
sans arrêt de recommencer ça nous
apporte rien de nouveau alors c'est un
effort pour qu'on puisse tous vivre les
restaurants fermés c'est une adhérence
total les différents cinémas fermés
erronée d'un écran acer nous on chausse
des personnes on a hâte de nos boutiques
c'est tout petit d'accord mais nous
avons toutes les mesures nécessaires
georges a rien coûté mais alors pourquoi
nous fermer pourquoi nous punir toujours
les mêmes les pauvres les petits jeux
très nous entendre sur la communication
des manuels macron il était à melun il a
lancé des pistes un bon rien de bien
certains finalement est ce que vous
auriez préféré qu'ils attendent le 5 mai
pour s'exprimer et donner je dire une
les grandes lignes définitivement tout à
fait parce que moi je trouve qu'on n'est
pas des enfants
donc ça nous dire des choses clairement
wahou boeuf qu'on disparaisse
complètement avait quand même cette
possibilité que ce soit les restaurants
les bars que tout disparaisse il dit
concrètement aux nachi dans ce cas là
nos fonds de commerce mais qu'on ne joue
pas au chat et à souris on ne peut plus
je vous avoue qu'on est en état de
détresse complète
je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de bandes
de pau vide en connectant de continuons
comme cela mais on va aussi beaucoup de
commerçants qui vont trouver très mal
après si un jour on peut vivre
normalement
justement c'est encore un petit peu flou
tout est incertain concernant le
calendrier de réouverture ça dépendra
évidemment de l'évolution de l'épidémie
d'ici les prochaines semaines
mais le gouvernement en tout cas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il promet un
protocole sanitaires strictes
frédéric jeanjean à quoi est ce que il
faut s'attendre
bon il ya des certainement les gestes
barrière qui seront encore évidemment en
vigueur mais est ce que vous attendez
vous à de nouvelles règles
a priori le protocole sanitaire qui
devraient être appliquées lors de la
réouverture est celui que nous avions à
l'automne dernier juste avant la
fermeture
mais il n'y a quand même un élément
qu'il faut souligner nous sommes tous
fermés tous pour éviter que l'hôpital de
soi attention nous ici à marseille
nous on l'a super d'apprendre que delhi
avait été fermé à l'hôpital alors on dit
qu'il faut éviter de l'hôpital son
attention et on ferme les lis et je
pense que c'est à peu près pareil
partout en france
alors vous savez je vous dirais
l'échangé une bonne fois pour toutes à
partir de maintenant je vais franchir un
seuil
je veux franchir un cap et je vais
rentrer un peu dans le débat politique
et je vais m'identifier aux candidats de
la république en marche puisque nous
sommes non essentiels il va y avoir des
élections
journal et des élections cantonales eh
bien je les reconnais tous les candidats
tous ministres quels qu'ils soient élus
locaux ou autres comme des candidats et
les hommes et femmes politiques nommé
essentielle je suis tout à fait d'accord
nous l'essentiel c'est à dire non
essentiels c'est à dire n'a pas besoin
d'eux puisqu'ils sont incapables de plus
donc on n'a pas besoin d'eux alors il ya
le 5 mai rebond kemal et le mettront que
teva s'exprimer est ce que vous attendez
de sa part qu'il prolonge les mesures de
soutien à la reprise et le maintien des
aides en courant et que tu es quand on
parle d est donc une belle parole mais
c'est une parole en l'air croyez moi je
ne recevrai rien donc il la plupart de
nos commerçants qui sont des personnes
qu un stock énorme notre métier fait
qu'on est obligé d'acheter d' avance
donc six mois d'avancé
nous n'avons des énormes stocks on
pourra pas les payer donc ça sera
l'industrie de la chaussure qui va être
mal après nous donc quand on entend des
z ça me fait rire parce qu'en fait
finalement si les tout petits êtres qui
ne savent même pas payer nos loyers ni
rien donc arrêtez de parler de nous
avons pas besoin d'être nous venons
travailler c'est tout bête mais nous
voulons simplement travailler hausse en
prison ne sont pas libres il t'a cette
nuit et puis les clients ne comprennent
pas
après ce qu'ils attrapent près en disant
me fait rien donc celui qu'on peut pas
niveau jeu sochaux c est comme pour les
restaurants et disparaît mais pourquoi
on peut pas ils ne comprennent pas en
fait
et moi non plus je ne comprends pas des
mesures qui ne sert à rien en fait
parce que quand j'entends que ça
continue à augmenter dans les hôpitaux
qui a de plus en plus de malades etc à
quoi ça a servi nous sert mais pour quoi
faire
pour rien donc je pense qu'il faut ici
trouver une autre solution
oui la guerre on a nation qui est prêt
depuis mois de janvier à ouvrir et ben
non le préfet l'état ne le permet pas
donc oui quand on veut faire avancer des
vaccins vont commencer au départ les
petits qu'il faut pas attendre que les
grandes villes
donc non je crois
qu'est ce que je comprends pas et on a
l'impression qu'on est
je dirai je ne veux pas parce que je
veux pas attaquer politiquement celui ci
ou celui là mais je trouve que mise à
part aux élus qui nous défend et qui est
toujours proche de nous personne
d'autres occupent de nous bon alors j'ai
évidemment les élus pour terminer là
dessus à mâcon qui s'est entretenu avec
une dizaine de mer cet après midi
justement en vue de ce plan de
déconfinement progressif et
territorialisée frédéric jeanjean est ce
que vous croyez que les élus vont être à
écouter parce que ils ont déjà eu des
consultations avec le président quelle
volte face rappelez-vous au début du
mandat
comme tous les corps intermédiaires
avaient été méprisés alors ce que je
veux vous dire au niveau du territoire
ici dans les bouches du rhône c'est que
ce soit le département la métropole la
région
tous nos élus ont été à nos côtés nous
ont accompagnés quelles que soient les
étiquettes politiques et quand je disais
tout à l'heure je reconnais comme non
essentiels les candidats la république
en marche
il ya quand même en dehors de ces gens
là ces gens non essentiels quand je les
reconnais comme nous non essentiels il
ya quand même un choix politique très
large de la droite à la gauche et de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
maintenant
ces gens qui ne sont pas capables de
gérer qui se retrouvent en situation de
fermer des lits ils se retrouvent en
situation de ne pas avoir de masques au
moment où il impose de les mettre qui se
retrouve à ne pas être capable mettre en
place une stratégie
rappelons nous monsieur salomon qui
avait oublié de commander les masques à
l'époque tous ces gens qui nous donnent
des leçons et qui se permettent
d'arriver et de nous mettre sous cloche
ça suffit basta est entendu merci à vous
frédéric jeanjean restaurateurs
secrétaire générale de l'umih 13 et
merci à vous également
isabelle se câlinent au présidente
d'honneur de l'association à commercial
iroise merci à vous et dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du plan de
relance européen
nous parlerons de bruno le maire plus
précisément le ministre de l'économie
qui presse bruxelles d'accélérer la
cadence pour la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan de relance
et puis nous parlerons du brésil où
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui une commission
d' enquête sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire alors que le pays enregistre
près de 400000 mordu coronavirus a tout
de suite sur rt france
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez 20h30 heure française
conférence de presse commune aujourd'hui
entre la france a et l'allemagne le
ministre français de l'économie bruno le
maire est le ministre allemand des
finances
olaf schulze ont dévoilé leur feuille de
route pour la reprise d'une conférence
de presse qui intervient alors que la
commission européenne a fixé la date
limite d'envoi au 30 avril l'occasion
peuvent bruno le maire d'exprimer par
ailleurs son agacement et son impatience
ils exhortent bruxelles à rendre
opérationnel le plan de relance en vos
perles 90 % des dépenses prévues dans le
plan à la mort sont consacrés à la lutte
contre le changement climatique et à la
transformation numérique
cela signifie que le gouvernement
allemand va bien au delà des objectifs
ambitieux fixés par l'union européenne
je pense que nous sommes sur la bonne
voie pas seulement l'allemagne et la
france mais aussi d'autres dations vous
avez déjà entendu que nous allons
maintenant présenter nos plans avec
l'italie et l'espagne
et nous travaillons avec la commission
et beaucoup d'autres pays font de même
en crise doit de 5 l'union européenne
doit compter sur ses propres forces et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec le plan
de relance européen
n'attendons pas des solutions des états
unis de la chine ou d'autres continents
attendons des solutions de nous mêmes
c'est cela être adulte
c'est cela être indépendant et on en
parle tout de suite avec un jacques
sapir à économistes bonsoir
jacques sapir merci d'être avec nous
bruno le maire qui pressent la
commission européenne d'examiner les
plans de relance nationaux il y a
urgence
oui tout à fait il ya tout à fait
urgence parce que maintenant on voit que
le retard est en train de s'accumuler
premier point il était prévu que ces
plans soient rendus il ya à peu près six
semaines la commission a donné un délai
supplémentaire parce qu'un certain
nombre de pays n'était pas prêt on
arrive là maintenant à la fin du dd on
est encore en train de soulever la
possibilité qu'il y ait un nouveau délai
parce que d'autres pays en particulier
l'italie disent que leur plan n'est pas
nécessairement bien ficelé bref il y a
un vrai problème de retard
on comprend aujourd'hui que au mieux les
premières sommes ne seront pas dégagés
avant septembre ou octobre prochain
autrement dit quinze à seize mois après
la signature du plan de relance par les
différents pays
oui il ya un vrai problème alors la
france elle table sur 40 milliards de
subventions européennes d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup moins que l'italie dans le
gouvernement dévoilé hier une aide
européenne de 191 milliards
est ce que notre économie elle est
beaucoup moins fragilisés finalement que
d'autres pays européens
comment expliquer ces disparités alors
on est effectivement moins toucher un
peu moins touchée que l'italie c'est
tout à fait exact
nous sommes quand même très largement
touché près il suffit de regarder le
recul du produit intérieur brut en 2020
nous avons reculé de 8,2 à 8,3 pour cent
l'italie a reculé de plus de neuf
presque de 10 l'espagne a reculé de 10
bon on est en fait compris dans un
espèce de deux blocs de pays du sud qui
ont été terriblement touchés à côté de
ça l'allemagne a été nettement moins
touchées et la moyenne au niveau de
l'union européenne
c'est un recul de seulement 6 6%
donc de toutes les manières
tous les pays auront des besoins alors
après il faut regarder est-ce que quel
est le niveau de la dette est ce que
certains pays peuvent mettre de l'argent
ou pas mais globalement ce plan est en
retard
ce plan est insuffisant 750 milliards
d'euros pour 457 millions d'habitants au
niveau de l'union européenne
alors que les américains pour le plan de
relance uniquement vont mettre 2,2
trillions autrement dit 2200 milliards
de dollars pour 350 millions d'habitants
on voit bien que la le compte n'y est
pas avec ses 40 milliards dès de la
france elle doit ajouter 60 milliards de
son propre budget quels sont les projets
qui vont être financés alors sur les 100
milliards du plan de relance
on veut financer différents types de
projets des projets qui touchent au
transport des projets qui touchent au
verdissement de l'économie
seulement en fait c'est pas 100
milliards qu'on va dépenser
parce que il y à toute une série de
projets qui sont concernés en fait non
pas par de l'argent frais mais pas des
déductions fiscales donc là déjà il ya
un problème même chose on dit qu'on va
soutenir les questions de santé
mais les projets qui sont intégrés dans
ce plan c'était des projets qui étaient
prévus par le ségur de la santé dont je
pense que la superficie réelle du plan
français elle est plutôt de l'ordre de
85 milliards pour les dépenses d'environ
10 ont 75 milliards à 75 à 80 milliards
pour les gir et les recettes réelles
donc de toutes les manières ce plan est
déjà un plan vraiment à minima pour nous
et ça va poser un problème extrêmement
important surtout que ce plan est censé
se dérouler sur les trois ans qui
viennent
et parmi les dossiers remis à bruxelles
il ya aussi les réformes que chaque pays
s'engage à effectuer en contrepartie de
l'argent qui lui sera versée pour
relancer son économie
quelle est la contrepartie que promet la
france alors la france promet comme
contrepartie effectivement de faire une
réforme des retraites qui la met au
niveau global de l'union européenne
elle promet aussi de faire des réformes
budgétaires de manière à maîtriser son
déficit
maintenant il faut dire que sérieusement
on ne voit pas la commission de
bruxelles bloquer le plan français parce
que toutes les réformes n'aurait pas été
appliquée même je dirais même si une
grande partie des réformes ne sont pas
appliquées ça c'est quand même quelque
chose dont il faut avoir conscience
conscience c'est que désormais je dirais
que là la surveillance par la commission
européenne sera relativement faible mais
c'est la contrepartie du fait que
l'effort consenti par l'union européenne
et lui aussi extrêmement faible merci
beaucoup à vous j'ai accepté je rappelle
que vous êtes économiser au brésil
jaillir gaulle son art au de plus en
plus fragilisée par à la crise sanitaire
à partir d'aujourd'hui une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire a étudié les
omissions du président brésilien et son
gouvernement en matière de gestion du
coronavirus plus d'un an après le début
de la pandémie
avec près de 400 mille morts le brésil
est le deuxième pays le plus endeuillé
au monde les détails c'est en images
[Musique]
oh
m
il
[Musique]
et dans ce contexte le brésil dit non
vaccin russes toute nouvelle agence de
régulation sanitaire brésilienne s'est
opposée à l'utilisation du vaccin sur
son territoire pourtant plusieurs états
brésiliens l'avait demandé pour faire
face à l'épidémie
mais l' agence estiment qu'elles
manquent de données sur sa sûreté son
efficacité elle attend que ce
pique-niqué soient validées par les
agences sanitaires européennes et
américaines pour le fonds
d'investissement russe qui a permis le
développement de ce vaccin il s'agit
d'une décision politique
jamais nous ne permettrons que des
millions de brésiliens soient exposés à
des produits sans une vérification
appropriées de la qualité de l'innocuité
et de l'efficacité ou au minimum face à
la situation grave que nous traversons
qu'il existe un rapport favorable entre
le risque et les avantages le report de
l'approbation de l'importation et de
l'utilisation du vaccin spoutnik v dans
le pays de la part de l' agence
nationale de régulation sanitaire du
brésil et malheureusement politique et
n'a rien à voir avec l'accès aux
informations sur le vaccin ou la science
on en parle tout de suite avec hervé
terrils géographe professeur à
l'université de sao paulo fin
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france
qu'est ce qui a poussé à l'ouverture de
cette commission parlementaire que
reproche-t-on au gouvernement brésilien
c'est pas très difficile à cinq ans
puisque le les services de la présidence
casas et vo a fait elle-même liste des
points sur lesquels les sénateurs
pourraient chatouiller le président ils
ont ils ont fait une liste de 23
manquement grave que le prudent le
président s'est rendu coupable
au cours de leur vie depuis le début de
la poudre de la crise qui vont du refus
que les vaccins dont vous venez de
parler d'état de d'occasion cours
desquelles il est sorti sans mas qui a
poussé les gens à sortir sans masquer sa
beauté les campagnes qui était fait une
vaccination est faite par les états tout
d'ici les propres services de la
présidence tout 23 raison de l'accusé si
vraiment il a une ardoise changé quelles
conséquences justement cette commission
denquête peut-elle avoir sur la
stratégie de derrière bolt somaro face à
l'épidémie
constitutionnellement cela l'institution
qui peut renverser le président c'est à
dire faire un des pitchouns à une
destitution c'est le sénat donc si le
sénat décide qu'il est coupable
il faut d'abord que la chambre des
députés le met en accusation ce n'est
parfait et il pourrait potentiellement
le faire ils ont déjà fait deux fois vu
que le président color des années 90 et
dilma rousseff en 2016 mais je pense pas
que ce soit très sérieux en fait je
pense que legault le groupement de
partis qui a appuyé
bodjona qui continuent à l'appuyer qui
vient de se prendre le contrôle du sénat
probablement fait plutôt monter les
enchères
c'est dire qu'il agite la menace l'eau
près du président pour obtenir encore
plus de ministère plus de crédits plus
de postes donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un moyen de renforcer leur
propre pouvoir au détriment de celui du
président et comme je vous le demande
est par rapport à la stratégie de
dearborn haro contre phase aller à la
pandémie
est-ce que ça peut changer
dan sylla si difficile à savoir ce que
je serai polir dix ans qu'il a eus d'une
stratégie imprévisible c'est à dire
qu'ils changent constamment d'altitude
quand il sent vraiment que la menace se
rapproche
il fait un certain nombre de concessions
mais dans l'ensemble il nous fait qu'est
ce qui lui passe par la tête et plus
récemment il a commencé de nouveau agité
la menace d'un coup d'état militaire qui
est probablement là aussi du bluff
puisque l'armée apparemment d'apollo est
décidé à suivre
oui il serait prêt à envoyer l'armée
pour mettre un terme au confinement
locaux on est ce que c'est sérieux
si rarement ses rues avec j au bosna le
milan n'a le pouvoir mais c'est quand
même tout à fait étrange ce serait le
seul pays au monde qui envoie l'armée
non pas pour renforcer le confinement
mais pour le supprimer
vous faites ça fait partie là aussi doté
d'une querelle politique qu'il a avec
les gouverneurs des états et notamment
l'état de son peuple qui est le plus
gros états de la fédération et 40
millions d'habitants et dont le
gouverneur qui mène une politique assez
active contre le coronavirus avec le
confinement en produisant des vaccins
dans la principale institution médicale
le saint paul fait de l'ombre au
président donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
souhaite contrecarrer la politique des
états qui luttent beaucoup plus
sérieusement contre le gouvernement
et cette commission denquête pourquoi
est-ce qu'un intervient maintenant
l'élection présidentielle qui se profile
en 2022 vous pensez que c'est l'une des
raisons
oui au parquet puis faire monter les
enchères comme je disais il espère
obtenir encore plus davantage du
président en le prenant un peu à la
gorge et donc il joue si je place
probablement pour l'élection qui vient
merci j'avais dans les attendait dans le
reportage parler de scouts ni qu'il faut
savoir que l'argentine vient de
l'accepter c'est peut-être aussi une des
raisons c'est peut-être un peu vexé que
l'argentine accepte public et donc le
brésil le refuse pour l'instant
merci beaucoup à vous hervé théry je
rappelle qu est géographe professeur à
l'université de sao paulo fait une
immersion maintenant à saint-pétersbourg
dans l' usine pharmaceutique de bio cad
qu'il produit justement ce vaccin
spoutnik v
nous avons tenté de répondre aux
questions sur la prétendue incapacité de
la russie à produire suffisamment de
vaccins c'est un reportage signé vera
goffman passer de deux à six millions de
kits par mois après une modernisation
février les usines pharmaceutiques bio
cad un des sept centres certifiés sur
les territoires russe pour fabriquer le
vaccin s'apprête à tripler sa production
de scouting et les spéculations de la
presse occidentale sur l'incapacité de
la russie à produire suffisamment de
vaccins même pour ses propres besoins
suscite une réaction de philosophique
chez la direction de bio cad
vous savez j'aime beaucoup cette
citation du mahatma gandhi d'abord ils
vous ignorent ensuite ils se moquent de
vous après ils vous combattent et enfin
vous gagnez nous avons fait face à cette
situation en mettant au point des
médicaments biotechnologiques et
maintenant mettant un point tel où tel
vaccin
j'estime que c'est une sorte de jeu ne
correspond pas à la réalité parce que la
russie déploie des efforts immenses pour
faire en sorte que le vaccin soit
accessible en premier lieu aux citoyens
russes
nous avons la chance de visiter le sens
des siens de lézinnes son laboratoire
pas question de se promener dans le
laboratoire en civil du coup nous sommes
obligés de mettre des costumes des ours
polaires
je suis prête la production se doublent
ainsi bio cad reçoit du matériel
cellulaire et viral depuis l'institut
gamaleya concepteur du vaccin puisse ont
développé des cellules qui sont ensuite
infectées avec du matériel viral
après la production du virus plusieurs
étapes de purification de celui ci sont
effectués ce n'est pas un boisson il
faut surtout pas le boire c'est
l'échantillon du futur vaccin
une fois que le vaccin est prêt il est
mise en doute l dites moi s'il vous
plaît à quel point le risque d'une
erreur humaine et il éliminer on ne peut
éliminer la possibilité d'une erreur
humaine mais nous l'avons réduite au
maximum chaque machine à ces points de
contrôle
ainsi s'il n'y a pas de notice alors
tout le paquet mis au rebut auparavant
la machine contrôler 100% de la
fabrication et le département qualité
vérifiée un flacon par paquet enfin le
tout est mis sur une palette par un
automate et la palette est transporté à
l'entrepôt nous tous sera congelée
chaque plat qu avant qu'elle soit
envoyée à l'emballage en cas d'un mot
gros défaut le plateau est cocu rejeté
par la machine alors que l'agencé
européenne des médicaments tarde à
donner son feu vert pour l'utilisation
de spoutnik vais sur le territoire de le
le vaccin russe est déjà enregistrée
dans 60 pays pour une population de 3
milliards de personnes et la russie
ambitionnent de remplir tous ses
engagements
on en vient la situation en main et de
plus en plus déchirante selon l' oms
en quelques jours le variant indien a
plongé le territoire dans le chaos et la
communauté internationale
elle s'organise pour venir en aide au
pays on voit cela avec rob actuelle le
cauchemar continue en inde
trois cent cinquante mille nouvelles
contaminations et plus de 2000 décès
sont enregistrés chaque jour des
chiffres certainement en dessous de la
réalité
tant les autorités indiennes semble
dépassé par la situation
le rebond soudain de l'épidémie a fait
exploser le système de santé du pays
les files d'attentes s'allongent devant
les pharmacies et les hôpitaux en manque
de matériel symbole de l'intensité de
cette nouvelle vague les crématoriums de
new delhi sont saturés certains sont
même forcés d'investir les parkings pour
faire face à l'afflux de dépouilles une
situation exceptionnelle à laquelle
n'ont jamais été confrontés les employés
la deuxième vague de covin 19 a commencé
vers le 5 ou 6 avril au départ cinq à
dix corps étaient amenés ici
mais hier nous avons eu un maximum de
122 crémation en une journée
hier et aujourd'hui nous avons dépassé
les 100 crémation les gens meurent
moeurs et meurent de plus en plus vite
et il n'y a aucun signe de
ralentissement
cela ne diminue pas mais augmente chaque
jour la communauté internationale
s'organise notamment pour pallier la
pénurie de matériel médical sans
ventilateur et 95 concentrateur
d'oxygène sont arrivés ce mardi en
provenance du royaume uni de son côté la
france devrait expédier huit unités de
production d'oxygène et 28 respirateur
d'ici la fin de semaine
la chine autre puissance de la région
vient également de promettre une aide
nous coordonnons est encourageant
également les entreprises chinoises à
reprendre activement aux besoins d'un
provisionnement de l'inde en
concentrateur d'oxygène et autres
matériels de lutte contre l'épidémie
la chine est prête à poursuivre la
coopération entier épidémique avec
l'inde de diverses manières afin d'aider
l'inde à lutter contre l'épidémie
afin d'endiguer l'épidémie les autorités
misent également sur l'accélération de
la campagne de vaccination
les etats unis devraient fournir de la
matière première pour la fabrication de
vaccins contre le coc vite 19 tandis
qu'une première cargaison de spoutnik v
sera envoyée par la russie en fin de
semaine en turquie le président richard
tayyip erdogan a annoncé un nouveau
confinement à compter de jeudi des
mesures strictes nécessaire selon
l'exécutif pour endiguer la propagation
du virus
depuis plusieurs semaines le pays
enregistre à un nombre alarmant de
nouveaux cas en fils points avec maxime
avère et arthur biskind la fin du
ramadan les turcs là passeront sous
cloche
annonce faite par recep tayyip erdogan à
l'issue de son conseil des ministres ce
lundi un confinement total de 17 jours
le plus long dans le pays depuis le
début de la pandémie les entreprises et
commerces non essentiels resteront
fermés et sauf cas de force majeure les
déplacements entre provinces interdit
des mesures acceptées mais néanmoins
difficile à vivre pour les habitants
ce sera difficile pour nous tous car
nous avons des impôts des loyers des
paiements à effectuer
nous avons des enfants ils doivent
étudier nous devons ramener de la
nourriture à la maison et nous vivons
dans une période où tout est très cher
nous allons traverser une période
troublée et difficile que dieu nous aide
c'est peut-être la bonne décision c'est
peut-être retarder mais juste c'est une
décision difficile pour les commerçants
pour les gens qui travaillent
l'état doit apporter une grande aide
l'épidémie bat des records en turquie 37
mille nouveaux cas ce lundi et des pics
à plus de 60000 contamination par jour
recensés depuis début avril
la russie a d'ailleurs suspendu ses vols
dans le pays jusqu'en juin avec ces
mesures le président turc souhaite
préserver la saison touristique qui doit
s'ouvrir dans les prochaines semaines et
soigner un secteur qui a perdu 65 % de
ses revenus en 2020 dans une période où
l'europe s'ouvre petit à petit nous
devons rapidement réduire notre nombre
de cas à moins de 5000
afin de ne pas rester à la traîne sinon
il sera inévitable de payer un lourd
tribut dans tous les domaines du
tourisme au commerce en passant par
l'éducation
ankara qui compte aussi sur sa campagne
de vaccination lancée en janvier
jusqu'ici elle s'est appuyée sur le
sérum chinois corona vac et sur ses
doses de pfizer bio ntech mais d'autres
solutions sont envisagées
ce lundi le fonds souverains russes a
annoncé un accord avec l'entreprise
pharmaceutique turc vis coran en vue de
la production du vaccin spoutnik v sur
les 83 millions d'habitants que compte
le pays
plus de 13 millions de personnes ont
reçu leur première dose à ce jour reste
avec nous pour la seconde partie de
l'émission
nous parlerons du bras de fer engagé par
l'union européenne contre
astrazeneca bruxelles poursuit le
laboratoire sous les eaux britanniques
l'union européenne dont certains pays
membres organisent des événements
culturels en guise de test en espagne un
confrère expérimental a rassemblé 5000
spectateurs restés avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
la nouvelle menace qui pèse sur
l'industrie une pénurie de matières
premières vous avez un phénomène qui est
le phénomène qui a fait monter tous les
actifs et qui ne sont pas forcément
d'actifs industriels des métaux ou autre
qui est l'inondation par les banques
centrales de monnaie et cette inondation
par les banques centrales de monnaie a
fait simplement grimper les prix vous
avez quand même à court terme avec les
livres namik entre l'offre et la demande
qui fait qu'avec le kobe 19 mai les prix
des matières premières se sont d'abord
effondrée c'était le cas sur le pétrole
et que l'on à une entreprise notamment
parce qu'il ya un pays qui est moins
touchée que les autres qui est le seul
pays qui a fait de la croissance
économique
officiellement abandonné blain qui est
la chine aujourd'hui c'est pas avec des
gesticulations en disant oh là là on va
manquer de telle ou telle matière
première le ca va relancer les choses et
que ça va permettre aux entreprises de
rouvrir
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qui nous troublent un
peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soient pas
publics parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
et
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine françois vient des lignes en
france aujourd'hui on a une gauche
l'extrême intéresse tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité comment
souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
tous les jours des groupes de pression
remettent en cause notre pays au niveau
de son histoire et ne s'intéresse qu'au
présent pour eux la souveraineté
nationale ou populaire est inacceptable
car assimilés aux régimes dictatoriaux
ou à une vision dépassée de l'intérêt
national
d'un autre côté des élites nous
encourage à abandonner l'idée de nation
française pour nous rallier à une robe
paré de toutes les vertus
malheureusement l'expérience montre que
si l'un des acteurs choisi de faire
cavalier seul en instaurant par exemple
des taxe protectionniste ou en mettant
en place des lois dissymétrique la
mondialisation se révèle un piège pour
tous les autres il faut avoir le courage
de faire le constat que l'europe à 27
noeuds permet de réaliser le vrai
consensus que sur des sujets mineurs ou
à la mode
[Musique]
mon
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis et que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le genre d'homme en avait
un autre combat on ma vie qui est celui
de la sécurité routière s'agit d'un
projet de loi qui vise à mettre en place
des tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit re doit
imposer loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information tout
de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 27 avril bruxelles engage le bras
de fer avec astrazeneca l'union
européenne a lancé une action en justice
contre le laboratoire celui du
britannique à lui reproche l'envoi de
seulement un quart de dos sur la
totalité prévues par le contrat
astrazeneca un vaccin marquée par une
forte défiance en europe à cause de
plusieurs cas mortels de thrombose
d'ailleurs le danemark et la norvège
cherche à écouler les doses du forum
[Musique]
l'union européenne à l'heure des
spectacles test un concert expérimental
réunissant faire mille personnes a été
donné fin mars à barcelone
conclusion aujourd'hui aucune contagion
selon les résultats cliniques à
bruxelles est un théâtre cobayes qui
donnera des représentations pendant
plusieurs semaines et en france un
concert tests pourraient aussi être
organisées d'ici 15 jours
un espoir de reprise donc pour le milieu
culturel au tchad des manifestations
contre les militaires violemment réprimé
le bilan au moins cinq personnes tuées
l'opposition et la société civile
reproche à la france d'avoir adoubé le
conseil militaire de transition tel juge
illégale une instance mise en place
après la mort du président idriss deby
itno
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron s'est dit
préoccupé par l'évolution de la
situation il a condamné la répression de
la contestation
[Musique]
plus de limite d'âge pour les tests
antigénique et les autotests une
décision de la haute autorité de santé
les moins de 15 ans comme les écoliers
de maternelle et de primaire pourront en
bénéficier
cela tombe bien puisque ils ont fait
leur rentrée hier la situation sanitaire
elle reste fragile
alors pour la haute autorité de santé
grâce aux résultats rapides de ces tests
est bien les dépistages de comics 19
seront facilitées et puis on en sait un
peu plus sur les étapes du déconfinement
hier le président a participé à la
rentrée scolaire
hamelin il a évoqué un couvre-feu plus
tardive et une réouverture des
restaurants au cas par cas
les déboires d'astrazeneca qui pourrait
faire le bonheur de zfs either biotech
en lançant une procédure contre le
laboratoire suédo britannique
la commission européenne a sans doute
entériné la fin des achats groupés de
doses d'astrazeneca un vaccin à
controversé que certains pays européens
ont de toute façon écartés de leurs
campagnes de vaccination
une situation dont pourrait bien
profiter les autres acteurs du marché
comme nous l'expliquent tomas menace
malheureusement le marché de la
vaccination n'échappe pas aux règles du
capitalisme
on sait par exemple que les brevets ne
sont toujours pas libérés malgré les
appels répétés en ce sens l'autre
facette de ce business
ce sont les contrats et leurs clauses
alors pour les vaccins astrazeneca
tarder à arriver
la commission européenne n'hésite pas à
lancer une action en justice
motif invoqué le non respect du contrat
c'est vrai que le laboratoire suède au
britannique est loin des objectifs fixés
initialement les doses reçues étant
nettement inférieure à celle commandée
les en lançant cette procédure
judiciaire la commission européenne sans
le dire met un terme à la collaboration
avec le laboratoire il est peu probable
que le vaccin astrazeneca soit nouveau
commandé par bruxelles d'autant que
certains pays comme le danemark par
exemple ont de toute façon déjà décidé
de s'en passer
une situation qui fait les affaires de
pfizer bio ventech déjà plébiscité le
vaccin du laboratoire américano allemand
devrait connaître une activité
croissante en plus des quelques 500
millions de doses commandées
bruxelles prévoit un nouvel accord
encore plus important
we were kings canyon tracts nous
travaillons gbe wendake fighter sur un
nouveau contrat sur contrat prévoit la
livraison de 1,1 milliard de doses pour
les amis et 2021 à 2023
et nous le conclure dans les prochains
jours mais garantira les doses
nécessaires ce pour administrer d
injection de rappel président natif
salle au virus togaf boost chasse
galerie en investissement à long terme
qui place meiser biotech dans une
situation de quasi monopole sur le
continent européen
un partenariat commercial assez opaque
mais des clauses du contrat ont été
révélées par nos confrères de tf1
et si on savait que les laboratoires
avaient négocié une exemption de
responsabilité juridique en cas de
problème
les détails du contrat révèle même que
c'est aux états membres que reviendrait
le coût d'éventuelles démarches
judiciaires
chaque état membre participant devra
indemniser et dégager de toute
responsabilité
le laboratoire ses filiales sous
traitants partenaires sous franchise
ainsi que ses dirigeants directeurs
employés et autres agents représentant
de chacune de ces entités en cas de
plainte d'un tiers relatives aux
dommages et préjudices qui surviendrait
lors de l'utilisation ou du déploiement
des vaccins sur le territoire de l'état
membre en question un contrat
particulièrement avantageux pour fire
que certains pourrait attribuer à la
situation exceptionnelle
bruxelles aurait mis le paquet pour
s'assurer un vaccin efficace et sans
danger
sauf que là encore les faits sont
coriaces si le battage médiatique autour
des cas de thrombose lié à l'astral et
n'est qu'à retourner l'opinion contre le
sérum suédo britannique des problèmes
existent aussi pour le kaiser
voici par exemple à un tableau
comparatif menée par le gouvernement
hongrois est relayée ici par le compte
officiel du vaccin spoutnik v on y
découvre que le nombre d'infections qui
suivent la vaccination avec du kaiser
est le deuxième total le plus élevé
derrière astrazeneca et pour ceux qui
douteraient de l'objectivité de ce
compte twitter officiel du sérum russe
il y a aussi ses statistiques en
provenance d'israël
pays entièrement vacciner avec pfizer et
ou de possibles liens entre la
vaccination et des cas de myocardite
chez des hommes jeunes sont actuellement
à l'étude en guyane aussi deux personnes
sont décédées du coït 19 alors qu'elle
avait pourtant reçu deux doses du vaccin
américano-allemand ses déboires
n'indique pas de manière évidente une
dangerosité du vaccin de pfizer mais
force est de constater que ces cas n'ont
pas été aussi activement relayée dans
les médias que ceux concernant
astrazeneca
le risque étant de laisser planer le
doute sur des vaccins qui pourrait
possiblement être privilégiés plutôt que
d'autres car si on accepte de manière
cynique que le marché de la vaccination
est un marché comme un autre alors les
règles doivent être les mêmes pour tous
et nous rejoignons gilbert collard
député européen du rassemblement
national
bonsoir avoue gilbert collard merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france
cette action en justice contre haas
astrazeneca ce que vous approuvez
d'abord oui pendant la charge des choses
puisque les doses commandées en partie
payé quand même à hauteur de 244
millions d'euros n'ont pas été livrées
tout simplement le premier trimestre il
devait y avoir 120 millions de doses il
y en a eu 30 le deuxième trimestre 180
millions il y en a eu 70 en corner on
est volé mais ça nous renvoie
directement à la manière dans les
contrats ont été négociés veut dire que
n'importe quel juriste d'entreprise qui
aurait signé un contrat de cette manière
là mériteraient d'être renvoyés sans
indemnité le licenciement bon quand vous
pensez et ça c'est un point important
que la clause qui lie l'union européenne
et les 27 états aux laboratoires
prévoient que les livraisons doivent
être faites
d'une manière raisonnable et que le
laboratoire doit faire de son mieux
il ya donc pas une obligation dite de
résultats mais a simplement une
obligation dite de moyens il suffira au
laboratoire de démontrer qu'il a fait
raisonnablement de son mieux puisque
c'est la clause intégré en anglais dans
le contrat pour qui s'exonère de toute
responsabilité
on n'a même pas eu l'idée de mettre des
dates butoirs dans le contrat on a pensé
à mettre des clauses exonératoire de
responsabilité
ça oui dans tous les contrats du reste
mais on s'est livré pieds et poings liés
blier comme des hommes des analystes
comme des comme des imbéciles au
laboratoire qui qui qui qui qui n'auront
qu'à dire qu'il n'était pas en mesure de
faire raisonnablement de leur mieux et
qu'ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
voilà que là vous pensez qu'un contrat
bien ciselé sur le plan juridique un ca
aurait permis d'éviter justement d'en
arriver là 30 millions de doses livrées
sur les 120 millions prévus oui à mes
yeux oui je pense à eux aux yeux de
beaucoup de juristes aussi ce qui fait
la lal la faille de ce contrat c'est
qu'il ya une glose tout à fait général
qui oblige
je m'excuse de le répéter le laboratoire
à faire raisonnablement de son mieux
alors il va être le procès va durer mais
des mois et des mois en plus est devant
un tribunal civil en belgique puisque le
contraire et de droit belge et on va
patienter pendant des mois des mois des
mois et des mois et des mois et des mois
avant qu'ils aient une décision
quelconque de versement de
dommages-intérêts donc c'est il ya deux
observations à faire si vous voulez la
première elle est d'ordre symbolique que
représente l'union européenne et si elle
n'est pas capable par son autorité même
à faire respecter un contrat dit tout à
l'heure on a été volé vous dites que
grattoir aussi n'était pas dans
l'obligation de remplir pleinement ce
contrat en avait-il les moyens
astrazeneca dénonce une logique en
justice attendent extra zeneca dénonce
une action justice sans fondement et se
justifie par un des vaccins difficile à
fabriquer à cause des contraintes
d'approvisionnement
ce que ça c'est un argument recevable
selon vous non je comprends moi bien je
ne dis pas que astrazeneca se comporte
bien
jeudi qu' ils sont comportés comme des
filous mais ils vont utiliser la ficelle
et il commence déjà du contrat de la
clause qui ne leur donne pas une
obligation de résultat
c'est à dire de livraison à une date
fixe je ne dis pas allez vous commander
n'importe quel produit vous demandez
qu'on vous le livre pour le 20 mai pour
le 30 mai pour le 15 juin
vous dites pas vous me livrer en
fonction de ce que vous pouvez
raisonnablement faire de mieux
parce que là vous mettez à la merci de
la livraison
on pourra faire quand on voudra donc il
y à vraiment avant la vie au niveau de
la rédaction du contrat une faille
maintenant
astrazeneca se comporte comme un voyou
de laboratoire en ne respectant pas les
engagements de livraison il avait pris
c'est juste un fait indiscutable ça des
autres groupes d autres laboratoires
oui les autres laboratoires euros
d'abord c'est d'avoir le précédemment le
problème de la qualité des vaccins
parce que à se raser les gars là est
dans la tempête par le fait de ce procès
il est clair que l'union européenne ce
qu'on aura plus vers lui et lui ne se
tournera plus vers elle
mais les autres vaccins présente aussi
des problèmes et les relais les
livraisons attendues aux heures dites
aujourd'hui n'arrive pas forcément bon
donc dans une situation qui est très
désordonnée et l'élimination
d'astrazeneca mettre fin aux heurts en
position de domination
ce qui est aussi quelques pas inquiétant
et pendant ce temps ce qui me permet d'
on ne réfléchit pas la question de la
thérapeutique et on exclut d'autres
vaccins qui pourrait entrer en lice 1 je
pense par exemple qu'est ce qui vous
inquiète particulièrement concernant le
vaccin father biotech des cas des cas de
thrombose les les signalements qui sont
faits ici ou là des accidents alors pas
forcément cataclysmique avait quand même
de plus en plus repérable chez des
personnes vous craignez que justement
les déboires d'astrazeneca ça permettra
father biotech d'avoir quasi monopole en
europe sur le marché des radios
l'élimination de croiser des cas pas par
sa forte 1 et puis aussi par les échecs
répétés des effets du vaccin
m faïza opposition de deux occupations
intériale totalitaire du marché et là je
peux vous dire que comme on est dans une
afrique
c'est horrible à dire mais si on fait de
l'argent sur la maladie sur la santé ça
va être d'une dureté inouïe et on est
quasiment pas en mesure de lutter quand
on voit encore une fois la manière dont
les contrats ont été discutés on est
désespérés quoi peut donc offrir l'union
européenne le soin de protéger notre
santé
et quand je pense que c'est elle qui va
encore régler la question du passeport
sanitaire il ya de quoi ne pouvoir
revendre de proches inquiétude les 27
qui sont sur la même longueur d'onde
pour une fois concernant justement la
stratégie vaccinale puisque tous se sont
montrés solidaires concernant cette
action en justice menée contre
astrazeneca votre réaction par rapport à
ça qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'il fasse
qu'est ce que voulait guy chasse au cul
battue et en puisque reller ils ne
peuvent et ne peuvent que ils ne peuvent
que s'unir dans dans l'action judiciaire
mais il faudrait pas non plus que cela
le procès fait à astrazeneca se
transforme en procès un bouc émissaire
car il faudrait pas que ça fasse oublier
tous les couacs qui ont été commis par
l'union européenne par les différents
pays la france sont à son tour
en l'administration des vaccins dans la
négociation des contrats dans
l'installation des vaccinodromes etc etc
on pourrait reprendre la litanie des
échecs on a l'impression qu'on va se
servir maintenant d'aider du procès fait
à 100 et les cas pour essayer de faire
oublier d'où les échecs les contrats de
l'union européenne qui n'ont pas été
consultés la clause vous rendez compte
des responsabilités c'est-à-dire qu'on
administre à des années à des citoyennes
et des citoyens un vaccin dont le
fabricant dit je ne vais pas être
responsable des dégâts qui pourraient
coûter vaccin vaccin pour fermer l'état
bien fonctionné quand même au royaume
uni sans succès astrazeneca
il est c'est un succès mais avec avec
des effets secondaires graves aussi on a
du mal si vous voulez à suivre vu le
combat médiatique de semaine les
laboratoires par agent médiatique
interposé car moi je suis pas un acquis
fin quand j'entends parler un
journaliste je me pose la question at il
des liens ou pas avec un laboratoire
pour quand on voit le combat médiatique
semaine les laboratoires en a un mal fou
à s'y retrouver mais que mémé la réalité
quand même puisqu'on parle de l'union
européenne c'est la manière dont les
contrats ont été rédigées et la manière
dont aujourd'hui devant les tribunaux
les 27 pays vont pouvoir demander des
comptes un laboratoire qui va peut-être
argumenté forte en facilement sur la
clause d'un contrat qui n'aurait jamais
dû être ainsi rédigé merci beaucoup
avoue gilbert collard je rappelle que
vous êtes député européen du
rassemblement national
depuis hier les enfants de maternelle et
de primaire sont de retour à l'école
l'école d'ailleurs où les purificateurs
d'air pourraient faire leur apparition
après avoir des noms dans un premier
temps le ministre de l'éducation
nationale encourage maintenant les
collectivités locales en l'installer
dans les établissements scolaires le
point avec estelle fâchent la copie
corrigée a été rendu le 22 avril est
dernier alors qu'il s'exprimait sur le
nouveau protocole sanitaire mise
place pour la rentrée scolaire du 26
avril le ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est finalement prononcé en
faveur des purificateurs d'air après
avoir longtemps exprimé sa réticence
nous encourageons les collectivités pour
les capteurs de co2 et les purificateurs
d'air cela fait d'ailleurs des mois que
cela s'est amorcée selon des modalités
qui varie d'un endroit à l'autre
nous sommes en partenariat avec les
collectivités chaque fois que sur
l'allée pertinents pourtant cela n'a pas
toujours été son discours en novembre
dernier chez france inter jean michel
blanquer études à l'appui balayé cette
option d'un revers de la main
évoquant l'inutilité des purificateurs
d'air voire même leur potentielle
dangerosité
il semble même que parfois ça renvoie le
virus moi je veux bien qu'on me démontre
le contraire
mais les études que j'ai à ma
disposition 10 cela des informations
quelque peu être démentie par nos
confrères d'ars telle étude de l'insee
ce brandit alors par le ministre évoque
certes parfois l'absence d'efficacité de
certains appareils
mais tous ne sont pas concernés par ce
défaut en son exemple par exemple les
appareils disposant d'un filtre hp a dit
à haute performance
invité du grand jury rtl lci le 25 avril
dernier jean michel blanquer a évoqué ce
changement de discours nous faisons
évoluer ce que nous disons en fonction
de ce que nous savons en france une
étude menée à l'échelon local en région
auvergne rhône-alpes eux démontrent que
les filtres h au péage site capture le
virus du coc vite 19 à plus de 99% ces
appareils pourraient donc faire leur
apparition en masse dans les écoles
comme dans les établissements scolaires
allemands ou espagnols qui ont déployé
ces dispositifs
depuis la rentrée 2020 à barcelone un
concert de 5000 personnes sans
distanciation social avait été organisée
à la fin du mois de mars
les spectateurs ont dû se soumettre à
des tests antigénique avant et après
l'événement le pointe avec thalys
listings l'ats sur place
c'est un succès appelée festival pour la
culture sur les résultats de ce concert
pilotes sont très claires l'événement
n'a pas eu d'impact sur la transmission
de la codi de 19 entre les participants
le 27 mars dernier près de 5000
personnes avaient assisté à un concert à
barcelone dans la plus grande salle de
la ville et sans distance sociale cette
expérience est le fruit d'une
collaboration entre les festivals
musicaux des professionnels de la santé
et des institutions
il avait mis en place un strict
protocole les participants devaient
avoir entre 18 et 65 ans il devait
porter un masque ffp2 et une prise de
température était effectué à l'entrée à
l'intérieur la piste est divisé en
plusieurs parties et un système
permettait de contrôler la qualité de
l'air le jour même les spectateurs
devaient obligatoirement effectuer un
test antigénique dans l'un des lieux
habilité pour l'événement et un mois
après on sait donc que sur les 5000
personnes seules six personnes ont été
positives dans les 14 jours après ce
concert dont 4 n'ont pas été contaminés
pendant l'événement alors tous et est
asymptomatique ou présenté de légers
symptômes
les organisateurs se disent très
satisfaits notamment route et mâcon
closer la conclusion finale et que selon
la cedh ans à 14 jours des assistants il
y a aucun signe qui suggèrent qu'il ya
eu transmission à l'intérieur des
installations du concert globalement
l'analyse des résultats indiquent en
concert live dans un endroit fermé
auquel assistent 5000 personnes qui
chantent et qui dansent qui peuvent se
prendre dans les lois en ayant passé un
test antigénique avant en portant un
masque ffp2 et avec une bonne
ventilation est une activité sur le
secteur assurances en voir le bout du
tunnel
il espère que cette expérience permettra
d'organiser des événements de grande
envergure et notamment des festivals
musicaux dès cet été à barcelone suite
avec philippe emmanuelli le médecin
libéral français justement à barcelone
bonsoir merci d'être en direct sur arte
france on viens de l'entendre c'est un
test cliniques concluants selon vous est
ce qu'il peut suffire à relancer les
événements culturels de ce type
oui bonsoir et bien dark donne la foi
voyant des mines et d'autres non il est
possible d'innover et par cette
expérimentation ouvre la porte au retour
des activités cultural de masse puisque
quand même c'est un test qui portait sur
5000 participants avec effectivement un
succès total garanti tout de même est la
sûreté sanitaire d'un espace comme cela
des des salles de concerts qui peuvent
accueillir 5000 personnes alors c'est
vrai qu'un protocole très strict a été
mise en place et après tout c'était un
protocole expérimental donc tout avait
été défini de façon très rationnelle et
qu'est ce qu'on peut
je dirais conclure de cette
expérimentation la première chose c'est
qu'effectivement la notion de densité
dans l'espace est importante c'est à
dire que d'ancêtres dans l'organisation
de cet événement on s'était attaché à
respecter une certaine densité par mètre
carré dans la salle de spectacle la
deuxième chose c'est évidemment lite est
bon dont on voit qu'ils sont
incontournables dans ce type de
stratégie et le troisième élément et
c'est pas c'est pas finalement le
moindre des éléments c'est effectivement
l'adhésion des spectateurs et la
discipline des spectateurs dans le
processus d'organisation
ça pose quand même une question sur la
fiabilité des tests
rien n'est certain à ce niveau alors si
vous voulez c'est vrai que oui et non
parce que pour que effectivement un
patient et un taux de contagiosité
important et bien effectivement il faut
plutôt qu'il soit symptomatique et les
tests antigénique
finalement dans cette expérimentation
grandeur nature ont montré tout leur
intérêt puisque effectivement même si on
a un taux final de 6 contaminés sur 5000
participants
donc je le rappelle 4 contaminée qui se
sont contaminées en dehors du concert ça
donne quand même une indication très
rassurante est très forte en faveur de
l'efficacité de ces tests sur ce type
d'événement
il ya un concertaient skate qui est en
train d'être organisées en france sous
l'égide du ministère de la santé
pourrait se tenir le 29 mai prochain
est-ce qu'il faut multiplier ses
expériences et jusqu'à quand pour
pouvoir les banaliser au final
écoutez ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
ne peut pas vivre sans la culture on
peut pas aujourd'hui ça fait un an et
demi que les pays européens ont baissé
leurs rideaux des principaux acteurs de
la culture
or la culture c'est le coeur de notre
vie est aujourd'hui effectivement tous
les moyens qui seront mis en oeuvre pour
remettre de la culture dans l'espace des
français des espagnols des européens en
général est une priorité nationale
alors d'un point de vue scientifique
vous pouvez répondre à cette question
ce genre d'expérience ça nous apprend
quoi sur le virus concrètement sa
transmission ça nous apprend quand même
beaucoup de choses en tout cas ça
confirme la stratégie mise en oeuvre en
espagne qui a une stratégie de pilotage
fin de l'épidémie avec je vous le
rappelle effectivement des restaurants
maintenant qu'ils sont ouverts depuis
relativement longtemps des espaces
publics qui sont préservés ça nous
rappelle l'importance 1 2
densité de population dans un lieu ça
nous rappelle également deuxièmement
l'efficacité des mesures barrières et ça
nous rappelle également l'importance de
la discipline de l'adhésion de la
population
merci beaucoup à vous philippe
emmanuelli je rappelle que vous êtes un
médecin libéral français à barcelone
autre expérimentation mais en belgique
cette fois hier a déjà le théâtre royal
flamand de bruxelles a permis à 50
spectateurs issus du milieu culturel
d'assister à une représentation les
spectateurs devaient être muni d'un
masque dans une salle hyper dense il est
surtout ont effectué un dépistage du
comique 19 avant et après le spectacle
et dès demain ce test sera énergie à 100
personnes la belgique qui ferme à ses
frontières par ailleurs aux voyageurs
venus d'inde du brésil et d'afrique du
sud en raison des variants présent dans
tous ces pays
le secteur n'est pas ouvert nous on
appelle la permission maintenant
d'organiser un événement espèrent on le
fait vie s'éteint pas mais ce n'est pas
pour tout le monde en ce moment il faut
vraiment que pour tout le monde que ce
soit les petits théâtres les grands
théâtres les lieux publics ou les privés
que tout le monde puisse ouvrir en toute
sécurité et en sachant que ce qui se
passe encore qu'on vit dans une pandémie
céder si on peut faire quelque chose si
on peut tester quelque chose qui n'a pas
encore été testée alors là maintenant on
va mesurer la qualité de l'air dans la
somme et si on constata que la qualité
de l'air reste pareil avec une jauge
très réduite et avec une jauge un peu
plus ce genre 200 300 400 personnes
alors on peut dire que une salle de
théâtre est un lieu vraiment
les gens peuvent être en toute sécurité
nous parlerons du rapport de l'eau angie
human rights watch qui accuse israël de
crime d'apartheid ce sera tout à l'heure
et puis nous évoquons le tchad cinq
personnes ont été tuées dans des
manifestations contre le conseil
militaire de transition emmanuel macron
un appel au calme
restez avec nous sur ft france
[Musique]
la gauche aujourd'hui et surtout faible
parce qu'elle a déçu parce qu'elle n'a
pas répondu aux attentes et aux espoirs
qui étaient placés en elle pour vous
c'est quoi finalement
l'enjeu principal les législatives où la
présidentielle nous souhaitons parler
avant tout à toutes celles et ceux qui
n'y croient plus qu'ils s'abstiennent
aujourd'hui voyez il ya énormément de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils ne veulent
plus aller voter puisque vous parlez de
ce nouveau souffle à gauche
cela s'inscrit dans l'eure dans un
rassemblement on a du mal à comprendre
l'idée d'une candidature communiste je
ne souhaite pas que dès maintenant on
nous dise et bien vous n'avez pas le
droit de présenter votre candidature de
quel droit aujourd'hui on pourrait dire
ça laissez les français décider oui le
parti communiste français souhaitent
pouvoir incarner l'alternative le
changement l'espoir
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative ressort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre
il est probable qu'il faille prendre un
certain nombre de mesures un peu
autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des souliers
vers une forme risquant même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
l'oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
et
baptiste et pour tout ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes veulent
s'évader du quartier qu'est ce qui ne
fonctionne pas dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les professeurs des écoles fonds
nécessaires mais je rencontre des
instituteurs des institutrices en ce1
ce2 il ya des enfants qui ont vraiment
encore du mal à lire et écrire mais
c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour la
famille on oublie les parents qui sont
responsables du foyer est temps que les
parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent pas le
français à la maison bas ça va être
difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france et vous
nous rejoignez 21h30 heure française
l ong human rights watch accuse israël
d'apartheid dans un rapport publié
aujourd'hui
en ligne de mire la politique
colonisatrice israélienne selon les mots
du document un rapport de 213 pages
explosifs ils dénoncent lé traitement
réservé par israël aux arabes au sein de
l'état hébreu et aux populations dans
les territoires palestiniens
de son côté israël dénonce je cite un
pamphlet de propagande
écoutez omar chakir et les directeurs
israël palestine à human rights watch et
eugène kantorowicz directeur d'un groupe
de réflexion conservateur a jerusalem le
gouvernement israélien rallye
aujourd'hui principalement sur la zone
située entre le jourdain et la mer
méditerranée en eau vive de groupe de
taille à peu près égales dans ces zones
le gouvernement israélien privilégie
méthodiquement les israéliens juifs en
les gouvernants selon un système unique
de loi et de privilèges tout en
réprimant systématiquement les
palestiniens divers degrés d'intensité
selon l'endroit où ils vivent
le raisonnement qui veut que la proche
de la communauté internationale s'agisse
d'une situation temporaire qu'un
processus de paix va bientôt réglée au
culte de la réalité de la domination
discriminatoire et bien ancré d'israël
sur les palestiniens est temps d'appeler
un chat un chat de reconnaître la
réalité telle qu'elle est la réalité
pour des millions de palestiniens et
l'apartheid et la persécution
le rapport n'est rien de plus qu'un
document de propagande plein
d'inexactitudes factuel et de
déformations et de réalité entièrement
alternative le rapport au delà de ce que
même le président palestinien mahmoud
abbas et la cour pénale internationale
ont dit la semaine dernière encore
mahmoud abbas a clairement indiqué qu'il
ne pensait pas qu israël était un état
d'apartheid
la cour pénale internationale qui
enquête sur israël depuis des années n'a
pas conclu qu israël était un état
d'apartheid
ce rapport n'est rien d'autre qu'une
fabrication de fantasmes de déclarations
erronées
de fausses représentations qui est
fondamentalement antisémite parce qu'il
est conçu pour rendre illégitime état
juif et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis tel aviv en israël avec
paula slayer journalistes pour rt
internationale elle c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir police
lier merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france
alors comment réagissent les autorités
israéliennes aux accusations d'human
rights watch
bilan les autorités israéliennes ont
rejeté le rapport de match ils ont
déclaré qu'il était absurde de cela il
faut et la grotesque
le ministre des affaires étrangères
israélien a publié une déclaration
disant que man rights watch est conduite
pour sa position anti israélienne et
qu'elle veut promouvoir le boycott
contre l'état hébreu
dans le même temps le fait que ce
rapport les pas été partagée avec les
autorités israéliennes avant la
publication ne lui ont pas permis de
produire des commentaires et cela
montrerait que la valeur de propagande
de ce rapport et son manque de
crédibilité
les autorités israéliennes souhaite
souligner le fait que la minorité
palestinienne bénéficier de tous les
temps du un dea droit civique que le
hamas a pris le pouvoir dans la bande de
gaza en cisjordanie les palestiniens
vivent sur des territoires disputés
sujet de négociation de ce pays et cela
justifierait les actions prises contre
les pats les chiliens pour des raisons
sécuritaires en tout premier lieu dans
ce rapport là c'est mort est très
importante puisqu'elle ong dénoncent des
faits d' apartheid sans comparer avec ce
qui s'est passé pour autant en l'afrique
du sud court proches lo n'diaye la
politique menée par israël vis-à-vis des
arabes sur son sol et des populations
palestiniennes et votre une intention
est de dominer les palestiniens il parle
de pression systématique d'actes
inhumains et tout cela équivaut à une
situation de partage
selon la convention des nations unies
sur l'apartheid
la définition de l'apartheid était
l'intention de par un couple tony sur
l'autre d'après human rights watch hrw
c'est le cas en israël il y à un déni
systématique par exemple des permis de
construire et les autorisations de
maison oui et en remuant des
restrictions deux ans à la liberté de
circulation sur des décennies
donc pour toutes ces raisons qu'il y à
un système d'apartheid
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'israël
est visé par de telles accusations
amnesty international dénonce également
depuis longtemps le blocus de gaza
instauré en 2007
thanks to make qui le subit les
critiques internationales
le blocus sur la bande de gaza est
illégal
il fut récemment il ya eu des
commentaires sur le fait qu'israël ne
fournit pas de 25 5 millions de
palestiniens qui vivent sur la bande de
gaza et en cisjordanie
contrairement à leurs obligations en
vertu du droit international en tant que
puissance occupante
[Musique]
les autorités israéliennes mènerait
également des campagnes de
discrimination et d'intimidation envers
des manifestants pacifiques palestiniens
ce ne sont que certaines accusations
lancées contre israël par des
organisations telles que amnesty
international alors prince d'ailleurs
quelles peuvent être les conséquences de
ce rapport pour israël alors qu'il ya
quelques semaines à peine la cour pénale
internationale
lancé à l'ouverture d'une enquête sur
d'éventuels crimes de guerre commis en
cisjordanie et dans la bande de gaza ont
transcrit shawish des conséquences
pourraient être très importantes
peut-être plutôt du côté symbolique et
diplomatique est que dans le fait vous
avez mentionné la cour pénale
internationale de la haye
ce rapport pourrait consister des
éléments de preuve pour la cour pénale
internationale
même si le gouvernement israélien a
déclaré que la cpi n'avait pas
d'autorité était biaisé contre l'état
hébreu ennemis humains certains pays de
la communauté internationale pourrait
reconnaître à la bastide en tant qu'etat
suite à ce rapport ou tout du moins leur
fournir plus d'assistance
cela pourrait également d'autre part à
renforcer les tensions entre les
israéliens et les palestiniens alors que
les négociations de paix n'ont pas
repris depuis presque une décennie d'eau
qu'il y aura sans doute des retombées
merci beaucoup pour l'asl ailleurs
journaliste pour rt internationale et
dans le reste de l'actualité en syrie le
retour des populations déplacées à la
frontière turque après plusieurs jours
d'intenses combats un cessez le feu
permanent a été signé dimanche entre les
milices kurdes liée au pkk et les forces
gouvernementales
des négociations menées sous l'égide de
la russie est les précisions de quentin
mauclair un retour au calme après près
d'une semaine de conflit meurtrier
à kamishli capitale de la région
autonome de facto du kurdistan syrien
des combats ont éclaté en début de
semaine dernière après l' attaque par
les troupes gouvernementales d'un poste
de contrôle tenu par les forces kurdes
conséquence plusieurs personnes ont été
tuées et d'autres blessées lors de ces
affrontements
dimanche dernier un cessez le feu
parrainé par la russie a été trouvé une
trêve permanente
arbitre et est garantie par les forces
gouvernementales et les forces russes a
été conclu dans la ville de qamichli les
forces de sécurité kurdes de la région
autonome du nord-est de la syrie
resteront attachés à cet accord tant
qu'il ne sera pas violé par d'autres
partis ce lundi des véhicules russes
patrouillent et pour veiller au respect
du cessez-le-feu
les centaines de civils contraints de
quitter la ville pour échapper au
conflit ont pu regagner leur domicile
un soulagement pour ces syriens qui
avaient dû plier bagages dans la
précipitation
les affrontements ont commencé nous
sommes partis aujourd'hui nous
retournons dans nos maisons nous étions
perdus sans maison nous n'avions même
pas d'eau dans la nature
maintenant nous sommes retournés dans
nos maisons pourrait résider à nouveau
si dieu le veut
cela fait une semaine et certaines
personnes n'avaient nulle part où
habitait les gens vivent et dorment et
dans les rues j'habitais dans une
mosquée pendant deux ou trois jours
grâce à dieu les gens sont de retour
chez eux maintenant nous nous voulions
pas que toutes ces choses arrivent nous
ne voulons pas de bombardements d'
attaque ni que tous ces civils show
déplacer la réalité que nous exigeons la
sécurité et la dignité pour les
populations
nous voulons que les choses soient
stables avec de la discipline
la sécurité et la paix et c'est tout ce
n'est pas la première fois que des
tensions éclatent à qamichli entre
anciens alliés de la guerre contre edf
le gouvernement syrien ne reconnaissant
pas l'autonomie revendiquée par les
kurdes
on passe à l'actualité africaine au
burkina faso trois ressortissants
européens ont été exécutés à la suite
d'une attaque dans l'est du pays une
attaque considérée comme terroriste par
des responsables burkinabè parmi eux
deux espagnols et un irlandais alors
disparition elle remonte juste après
l'offensive de plusieurs assassins
assaillants pardon armés circulant à
bord de deux véhicules et d'une dizaine
de motos les victimes participaient à
une mission humanitaire en tant que
journaliste formateur
le burkina faso est régulièrement la
cible d'attaqués terroristes
c'est un pays et membres du g5 sel comme
le tchad d'ailleurs un pays aujourd'hui
plonger un peu plus dans la tourmente
depuis à la mort de son président idriss
deby itno depuis un conseil un militaire
dirigée par son fils est en place et au
moins cinq personnes ont été tuées
aujourd'hui lors de manifestations
contre ce pouvoir militaire contesté par
l'opposition mais aussi la société
civile qui reproche à la france de
soutenir une instance dite illégale
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron s'est
exprimé sur la situation là bas est à
l'issue d'une rencontre d'ailleurs avec
son homologue congolais félix tu sais
qui dit le président en français qui
condamne la répression au tchad en
écoute aujourd'hui avant toute chose
nous voulons exprimer notre
préoccupation sur l'évolution de la
situation en condamnant d'abord avec la
plus grande fermeté la répression des
manifestations et des violences qui ont
eu lieu ce matin
n'djamena j'ai apporté mon soutien à
l'un de l'intégrité et la stabilité du
tchad très clairement n'djamena je suis
pour une transition pacifique
démocratique inclusive
je ne suis pas pour un plan de
succession le temps est venu de lancer
un dialogue politique national ouvert à
tous les tchadiens
c'est ce qui est attendu aujourd'hui des
conseils militaires de transition et
c'est la condition même de notre soutien
face aux violences des habitants de la
capitale
tchadienne n'djamena ont réagi avec
colère écoutez si je la bonne mémoire
ils ont dit les doigts de manifestation
s'est tenue dans l'air dans les rues
qu'on avait dit dans leurs textes cours
actuel mais monsieur surpris à 4 à 5
heures en raison là qu'avec le modèle
par tous les enfants les innocents pour
la pluie on la lit côté roma et suis
choqué c'est pas digne d'un gouvernement
il faut il faut que les gens manifestent
c'est pour lesparre à revendiquer notre
l'inclusion
le dialogue n'est ce pas et donc c'est
normal c'est normal que la population
puisse se soulève et se soulever contre
la position de la france cela et on en
parle tout de suite avec léo koungou il
est politologue spécialiste en relations
internationales
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord un point
sur la situation tendue au tchad
on parle de 7 morts au moins neuf
peut-être selon un bilan d'une ong donc
les chiffres sont pas encore tout à fait
précis
est-ce que la situation elle est en
train de dégénérer là bas je n'ai pas
d'enfant
on va rétablir on va rétablir la
l'élision peut-être on va essayer de
rétablir les liaisons avec vous est-ce
que vous n'entendez les hong kong ou
willin j'entends des gens d'abord un
point sur la situation au tchad il ya
des manifestations qui sont réprimées
on parle de 7 voire neuf morts selon une
ong
est ce que cette situation elle est en
train de dégénérer je pense que la
situation va dire n'est pas totalement
un train de dégénérer mais il était
question c'est à dire définir de la
ligne politique du conseil militaire de
transition qui a été mis en place et
notamment le rôle qui pourrait être
celui de la france comme vous le savez
au premier de cette situation la france
a immédiatement apporté son soutien au
conseil militaire de transition beaucoup
de nombreux tchadiens notamment
l'opinion publique et même les
politiques cela et a été appréhendé
comme étant un soutien apporté à une
succession dynastique au sommet de
l'état voilà pourquoi il était de bon
ton pour le président marc long
lorsqu'il a pris la parole aujourd'hui
des dicos fait la france avait apporté
soutien compte tenu de l'urgence des
situations à savoir la rébellion qui
arrivait de dia mais n'a et qu'il n'est
en aucun cas question de soutenir une
quelconque succession dynastique à la
tête de l'état la france soutient donc
le processus démocratique et je pense
que c'est pardon chiffrant à apaiser sa
a dit rené zester mais ce que nous dit
c'est que la france à quelques pains
directement une part de responsabilité
sur les manifestations que l'on observe
aujourd'hui
au tchad la manifestation elle au fait
des leaders politiques notamment
monsieur succès marmara qui a réussi à
mettre des jeunes est dans la rue c'est
parce que comme je le souligne un y
avait combiné
le président deby est décédé et à la
tête du conseil militaire des
transitions se trouvera son fils mamad
débit pour certaines opérations d
notamment lors des funérailles
on a vu des faits reportés en djamena
dirigeants et notamment le président
marc roux qui sont venus comme pour
adouber la transition qui avait été mise
en place
voilà pourquoi certains ont qualifié
cela de coûts des cas et je pense que ce
sont ces manifestations que l'on pouvait
dans la rue ou dénoncer une situation
sadique qui violerait l'ordre
constitutionnel et à partir du moment où
la france pendant la parole pour dire
que tel n'est pas le cas et qu'elle
soutenait sardines ou dénouer membres
d'une transition démocratique
je pense que cela suffira à apaiser or
justement c'est ce qu'il a tenté de
faire de désamorcer un peu la situation
humaine elle macron la position
française vis-à-vis de ce conseil
militaire de transition au tchad
puisqu'il a dit je ne suis pas pour un
plan de succession on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure vous qu'on sait que ce sera
suffisant pour apaiser la situation là
bas
l'opposition et la société civile je
pense que cela n'est pas tout à fait
suffisant mais il faut comprendre la
situation dans laquelle le pays est
plongé aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
les rebelles en enlevant la vie à au
président déby que ça dure et qui devait
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
leur objectif est de prendre n'djamena
donc il faut donc mettre sur pied un
mécanisme ce à dire qu'ils puissent ne
serait ce que pour cette situation
d'urgence
encadré le pays ça dit la souveraineté
du pays
voilà pourquoi la france dans un premier
temps c'est à dire comme le président
marc on l'a si bien souligné il était
question ça dure et d'apporter tout le
soutien
à cete institutions soutien politique
mais aussi soutient me dis qu'un et pas
trop moment nous pardon et convient de
souligner que les positions des rebelles
ont été bombardés sa grâce au soutien
français
je pensais donc la transition qui a été
mise en place à lille pour 18 mois
elle est appelée à organiser un dialogue
inclusif qui réunira tous les tous les
tchadiens et à l'issue de ce dialogue
on a un on ira au fait dans tous les cas
vers des élections libres
vous croyez que le fisc et d'idriss deby
itno défunt président il doit s'exprimer
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a annoncé marc
amateurs idriss deby vous croyez qu'il
va qu'il peut assurer lui cette
transition et et transférer le pouvoir à
au civil dans tous les cas fait que le
conseil militaire de transition s'est
engagé pour 18 mois et il convient de
souligner que dans ces dix huit mois
c'est à dire il ya dernier la communauté
internationale notamment l'union
africaine par la voix de son président
félix et qui c'est qui dit qui a demandé
à ce que les voies démocratiques soient
observés c'est à dire en matière de
transition
mais il ya aussi le nord de la france
qui jusqu'à napo de nombreux
observateurs étaient assez flou
maintenant que la france attire marc
estimé sa position c'est à dire vers des
élections qui seraient démocratique
je pense que les militaires au pouvoir à
niamey n'a n'ont pas suffisamment de
moyens c'est à dire pour contrôler le
pouvoir au delà de cette période parce
qu'ils convient de le souligner si la
rébellion n'est pas arrivé à dia menacer
sous débarquent en deçà d'une opération
militaire française qui a dû bombardé
certaines de nos positions pour qu'ils
ne parviennent pas à 9
alors justement vous avez précisé par
les deux flics qui s'était dit le
président de la république démocratique
du congo qui est à paris aujourd'hui qui
a rencontré macron se sont exprimés sur
le tchad il dirait
aujourd'hui la présidence tournante de
l'union africaine est-ce que la rdc va
jouer un rôle justement pour permettre
au tchad de se stabiliser et de
repousser
justement les positions rebelles je
pense que vous faites la rdc en tant que
pays souverain c'est à dire n'a pas
forcément je dirais les moyens qui
seraient militaires voire fait
diplomatique pour apporter un quelconque
soutien route yade la rdc s'estime pas
la voix de son président qui en même
temps président de l'union africaine il
s'agit donc c'est à dire d'envoyer la
communauté internationale vers les
principes qui régissent l'union
africaine à savoir le respect des
principes démocratiques les transitions
de pouvoir a dit qu'ils doivent se faire
par des élections libres
mais la ldc également par la voix de son
président c'est à dire va s'appuyer sur
des mécanismes internationaux notamment
les nations unies mais aussi l'union
européenne ce n'est pas gênant ce hasard
de calendrier sont que dire des choses
ainsi la présence des présidents
congolais à à paris aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas à fait que ce soit un hasard
de calendrier
nos présidents congolais et le président
marc l'on s'était déjà vu la semaine
dernière aux funérailles du président
deby mais le président qui sait que dix
devaient également passés en france
parce que il faut quand même le
souligner en tant que président en
exercice de l'union africaine
il est au coeur de plusieurs événements
qui réuniront la france et l'afrique
dans les prochains jours je voulais dire
ce que je voulais sous-entendre en fait
c'est que c'est on entend peu les
institutions panafricaines sur la
situation au tchad en afrique centrale
est beaucoup plus la voix de la france
mais comme on l'a toujours souligné
c'est à dire
l'union africaine a en elle même sa
poupée que ce soit l'union africaine sud
au plan global où les institutions sous
régionales
ce sont c'est à dire des généraux sans
troupe parce que derrière il faut une
certaine contrainte et vous comprenez
que c'est à dire la voix de la france
pèse significativement parce que je suis
le plan militaire la france est présente
elle est déjà présente à dire en djamena
à travers de l'opération épervier qui
date des années 1990
mais il faut également souligner que
l'opération d'un canapé au quartier
général djamena et à côté de ça c'est à
dire vous avez presque 500 hommes
stationnés à dire en charge et de
contourner la situation dans l'ombre ans
qu'il n'ait pas joué dans ce plan n'est
pas beaucoup vu l'immensité de la région
du sel en défis pour la france aussi de
d'être impliqué dans les événements ah
oui en plus du mali et oui oui partie de
la mauritanie jusqu'au soudan c'est à
peu près 3 millions de kilomètres carrés
mais il faut quand même le souvenir que
fait la france est déjà présent en train
de mobiliser ses partenaires pour
pouvoir apporter un début de solution à
différents défis sécurité qui se posent
et je pense que c'est ce poids
significatif qui ad'ailleurs permet
comme je le soulignais dante aux
rebelles de ne pas arriver en djamena
voilà pourquoi de façon tellement
dramatiques cead il est question de
s'appuyer la france que de s'appuyer sur
les instances sous régionale qui peuvent
condamner mais n'ont pas de moyens de
contrainte pour pouvoir obtenir la
situation sur le terrain et pour
terminer très rapidement à votre avis
l'issue de de cette situation ces
tensions au tchad la situation en fait
en elle-même et convient de souligner
que le conseil militaire de transition
il est vraiment entre le marteau et
l'enclume parce que il ya là une triple
je dirais
pression qui savent a su compenser cela
dit il ya déjà c'est sa discrétion de la
rébellion qui n'a pas désarmé qui a fait
un repli stratégique dans des pays tels
que le niger et qu'il deviendra c'est à
dire lorsque la situation se sera calmé
il y à aussi c'est à dire la pression
est-elle à savoir l'opposition
démocratique qui voudraient s'attirer
une transition qui l'opposait sur les
principes vraiment démocratique mais
aussi il ya la pression internationale
mais nations unis mais aussi la france
qui est d'avancer de cette transition
aujourd'hui et je pense qu au delà de
toutes ces tensions
nos délai de 18 mois ce à dire sera sous
pull heureusement observer et il n'est
pas question ici c'est à dire de vivre
une transition sané qui va s'éterniser
merci beaucoup à vous allez hong kong où
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
spécialiste en relations internationales
et c'est la fin de cette émission
prochain pas complet sur l'actualité ce
sera dans quelques minutes rester avec
nos supporters
[Musique]